over this weekend we surpassed a
major coveted vaccination milestone
and we came very close to surpassing
another
on saturday the u.s injected 2.9
million vaccines into people's arms
almost half a million more than the
previous single day record of about 2.4
million vaccines in a day
and we are just shy of three million
vaccines a day
that is a real possibility in the three
days this past weekend friday saturday
sunday
more than 7.7 million vaccines were
injected in just
three days these are the types of
numbers that will turn the pandemic
around if they can be sustained
look at how quickly this has ramped up
when donald trump left office
the seven day average of vaccinations
was
890 000 a day thanks to joe biden
working with pfizer and moderna to ramp
up supply to states and getting the
vaccine to states importantly
because we had this situation under
trump where pfizer and moderna were
reporting deliveries
and yet hospitals and clinics were
saying we don't have the vaccines
so that has been improved we now have
the addition of a third vaccine we may
have a fourth vaccine
we are now averaging 2.16 million doses
per day over the last week
we have a new high water mark of 2.9
million vaccines in a single day
right now by percentage the leading
states on vaccination are new mexico
alaska connecticut
the dakotas rhode island and
massachusetts
states doing the worst on vaccination
percentage-wise
are georgia washington dc which isn't a
state
um alabama texas utah and tennessee
i believe that in the next week possibly
saturday that seems to be the big
vaccination day every week
we will get to 3 million vaccines in a
single day
and if you can make that steady you are
dramatically improving the timeline
on herd immunity compared to just doing
a million vaccines a day you're
you are moving it up uh in fact by
two-thirds
um the math of this is that if
we can accelerate to about three million
doses per day we are looking at maybe
three months
until we start getting into the range of
what we would consider to be herd
immunity
um could be could be three could be four
it could be two and a half
you know if we get to four million doses
a day we could really get even closer
it's not worth calculating it with too
much precision there's no sense in
saying
may 10th will be the day does it you
know that things change and shift
but when you think about three and a
half million a day
that's 210 million doses in 60 days
if you assume 80 of those are the two
shot regimen
and the rest are the one shot you're
maybe looking at fully vaccinating 125
million people in the next two months
30 million are already vaccinated and
then that means that like maybe one more
month
you know 90 days from now we are
starting to get into the range
of herd immunity now there's tons of
work to be done we're racing
against variants against which the
vaccines are not quite as effective in
terms of preventing illness preventing
disease altogether but very effective at
preventing serious disease disease and
hospitalization and death
so there's there's still a lot going on
here and in the next couple of days the
cdc will put out
new guidelines for vaccinated people i
expect
that reading that will encourage more
people to want the vaccine it's
anticipated the cdc will say it's fine
for vaccinated people to gather indoors
in small groups with no masks
i i my thought is that as people start
to see these vaccines actually do have
an
impact on not only the nationwide
numbers but what you can do
that more and more people are going to
want the vaccine and as soon as the cdc
puts out those guidelines we will have
them for you
a very exciting on march 26th
we are going to be doing our next single
day membership special we haven't done
one of these for months
i wish i could tell you there was some
really exciting reason why we're doing
it
the reason we're doing it is february
was the worst month in more than a year
from the standpoint of memberships
the economic situation has led to a lot
of people having to cancel memberships
february being only 28 days
left literally fewer days for people to
sign up february was
a disastrous month for us as far as
memberships go so we are going to have
a one-day huge membership blowout
friday march 26th if you want to be
notified about this membership special
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com real easy
and then a friday morning march 26th you
will get a perfect email
with a spectacular coupon code telling
you exactly how to
sign up at what is close to an illegal
discount it's certainly an immoral
discount
it may even be illegal in some states
but don't worry
nobody's going after anybody for this
stuff so get on the newsletter mailing
list at davidpakman.com
let me know your thoughts on vaccination
and how it's going you can find me
on twitter at deepakman the more we
learn
about various diets around the world the
more we realize
that some of the healthiest diets where
folks are living the healthiest and the
longest
are heavily plant-based and one of our
sponsors
just egg is a great place to start just
egg
cooks and tastes just like real eggs
but it's made from plants it has less
saturated fat
no cholesterol packed with protein i've
been cooking with just
egg at home and you can use it
in so many different ways just like
traditional eggs omelets scrambled eggs
french toast
banana bread one of my favorite dishes
pad thai
it also is better for the planet
generating 93
fewer carbon emissions and 98
less water than conventional eggs
you can find just egg at lots of grocery
stores
whole foods kroger amazon prime
now and instacart check it out just egg
really is a great product from a company
with a great mission
and i'm really glad that they're a
sponsor of the show